justo aquí se muestra la gráfica de que
igual a 1 entre x cuadrada la pregunta
que quiero hacerte es cuál es el límite
de 1 entre x cuadrada cuando x tiende a
0 pausa el vídeo e intenta responder
bueno cuando intenté responder
observarás de manera inmediata que algo
interesante ocurre en x igual a 0 cuando
nos acercamos a 0 por la izquierda y
evaluamos la función 1 / x cuadrada
obtenemos valores más y más grandes
esto no se aproxima a un valor finito es
decir es
no ha cortado no tiene cuota alguna lo
mismo sucede si nos acercamos por la
derecha si nos acercamos cada vez más y
más a 0 por la derecha obtenemos valores
más y más grandes para 1 / x cuadrada
sin ninguna cota una terminología que a
veces se usará en esta situación donde
ambos van en la misma dirección pero no
es acotado será que el límite es no
acotado
en algunos contextos escucharás a tus
profesores decir que este límite no
existe y bueno si pensamos en obtener un
valor finito entonces en definitiva no
existe en vídeos futuros empezaremos a
introducir la idea del infinito y una
anotación que relacione los límites con
el infinito donde podemos ser un poco
más específicos sobre qué tipo de límite
es este bien con esto en mente veamos
otro escenario ahora se muestra esta
gráfica de aquí que puedes reconocer que
es la gráfica de la función y igual a 1
entre
así que te preguntaré lo mismo pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrar el límite de 1
entre x cuando x tiende a 0 pausa el
vídeo e intenta encontrarlo
bien en esta ocasión cuando nos
aproximamos por la izquierda obtenemos
valores más y más negativos
mientras que cuando nos aproximamos por
la derecha obtenemos valores más y más
positivos en esta situación en donde el
límite es no acotado pero va en
distintas direcciones recuerda en el
ejemplo anterior teníamos un límite que
no estaba acotado pero que tanto por la
derecha como por la izquierda iba en
dirección positiva sin embargo aquí por
la izquierda vamos en dirección negativa
y por la derecha vamos en dirección
positiva entonces si piensas en el
límite cuando nos aproximamos a un punto
y no nos aproximamos al mismo valor oa
la misma dirección entonces claramente
diremos que el límite no existe así que
en esta ocasión tenemos la situación
donde el límite es no acotado pero
apuntamos en diferentes direcciones
cuando nos acercamos por la derecha que
cuando nos acercamos por la izquierda
entonces diremos que el límite no
espero que esto te sea de ayuda nos
vemos en otro vídeo